news virtual reality simulation activate
hey guys it's Thursday August sixth I'm
Mary Kish and this is gamespot news
first up if you were worried that Final
Fantasy 15 was going to be in
development for like a kajillion years
worry no more because a release window
has been confirmed for 2016 Final
Fantasy 15 director Hajime Tabata has
confirmed a game spot the fans can
expect to play the game before 2017
indicating the game will be released in
2016 when asked about the release date
to bots are applied at the very least I
can tell you that it isn't going to be
released this year I think we'll be able
to tell you when we're making an
announcement around PAX Prime at the end
of this month we can certainly say to
people it's not going to be 2017 it'll
be before that we got a bunch of details
on the anticipated expansion of MMO
juggernaut world warcraft here's
everything we know about Legion this is
the sixth expansion for World of
Warcraft and it adds a new continent
named broken Isles broken Isles has
never been playable before but it was
referenced in warcraft 3 broken Isles
has forests mountain ranges and even
elven cities what's more Legion raises
Wow's level cap 210 and introduces a new
class called demon hunter there are also
new dungeons and raids to explore as
well as new artifact weapons and an
honor system but who cares let's talk
about demon hunter the character can
double jump and it's creepy-looking
wings let it perform gliding attacks to
surprise from above in addition demon
hunters are blind so they rely on
magically augmented sight to see also
known as the daredevil method Blizzard
has not announced a release date for
legion we already know that destiny dev
dumped dinklage like a sack of wizards
from the moon but now we know why that
wizard came from the moon bungees hired
voice actor nolan north to be the new
voice of the in-game ghost companion he
hasn't just been brought on for the
expansion though he's rerecording every
line of dialogue in the entire game
completely replacing Game of Thrones
actor Peter Dinklage who was the
original voice of your ghost Destiny's
lead concept artist jessi van dyk
explained that Bungie wanted to
work the entire game to make it more
clear and guide players even more this
is why nolan north is also your ghost
from the very moment you start the game
the taken King launches on September 15
lastly time magazine's cover features
Palmer Luckey wearing oculus mid dance
on the beach the internet has been quick
to respond to the image with much better
places you can put lucky here's a few of
the ones we like ooh that's a good one
my personal favorite is the Cyclops ooh
that's cute looking good lucky it's like
being at the beach but I don't even have
to worry about a sunburn well that's it
for today you guys I'll see you again
tomorrow for another gamespot news see
you then huh
that it throughout that's a news